until fairly recently the the position
of opposition to the European Union was
always a mainstream position on the Left
it's only over more recent years that
much of the left has turned into a bit
of a fanatical Club in favor of the EU
so if you go back a little way you can
look at people like Tony Benn and Bob
crow the general secretary late Bob crow
general secretary of the RMT and Jeremy
Corbyn Shore and Barbara castle and and
real big hitters like that in the in the
labor movement who were opposed to the
European Union and predominantly because
they saw it as what it is an
anti-democratic and anti-socialist
institution an institution that embeds
austerity embeds deflationary economics
and you know the view of people on the
left is that actually as socialists
we're in favor of things like public
ownership whereas the EU is much more
geared towards privatization we're in
favor of investment even at times of
recession and when the economy's
flatlining errors do you you
particularly if you look at what it did
to Greece is much more in favour of a
kind of neoliberal approach to these
sorts of things and from the point of
view of socialists you've got to be able
to elect some remove the people who
govern you that's a fundamental
principle it should be a fundamental
principle for anybody on the Left
they're actually the people who are
making your laws and the people who have
a large say over your economy must be
accountable to the people and in many
cases they're not and always remember
the five questions that's only been used
to ask he said whenever you met anyone
famous I used to ask five questions what
power have you got how did you get it in
whose interest to you exercise it to
whom are you accountable and how can we
get rid of you what's the popular course
in the end
but back in his 1870s he was absolutely
and it's that fifth question you know
how can we get rid of you which goes to
the heart I think of the debate about
the debate about the European Union
you've got to have power over the people
who ultimately are making your laws and
in many cases directives and regulations
come from the EU which the which members
of parliament have no say on and we as
citizens of this country have to have to
abide by you can then get into the more
technical details and talk about things
like restrictions on state eight so at
the moment for example there's a huge
debate around whether we should
nationalize British still in light of
the problems it's been experiencing over
the last few days and actually if you
look at any regulations we can't do that
because they have because it's so in
favor of market forces they have to have
what they call this level playing field
so state aid from countries which give
in their view and unfair leg up to
particular companies is wrong and in
fact in 2016 year you find the Italian
and Belgian governments third for trying
to rescue failing steel makers by biting
them out you've got things like the
stability and growth pact which says
that member states cannot run a budget
deficit of more than three percent of
GDP
now anyone who sort of understands
economics in terms of the right approach
to tackling a flat line in economy and
recession what Maynard Keynes taught us
in the nineteen thirties is that
actually you need to maintain levels of
investment during that recession because
if the government cuts and slashes at a
time when everybody else is doing it no
one's going to create a recovery so it's
the government's job to sort of hold the
line and that stability and growth pact
makes it very very difficult to do that
so in effect they've ruled out Maynard
Keynes II Keynesian economics from from
the EU and then you can look at the you
know the mass unemployment that's taking
place across Europe you can look at the
renewed tensions that have appeared
between particular company countries
Germany and Greece for example so all in
all this idea that the EU is some
progressive benevolent democratic
organization which is in favor of
workers and in favor of the interests of
ordinary people
he's a total and utter nonsense and and
the left-wing case was always built
around some of the
stuff that I just said but but now
unfortunately so many people on the Left
seem to have fallen in love with it
[Music]